hey everyone how's it going welcome back
to my JavaScript crash course for
beginners series what I'm going to talk
about today is JavaScript functions
explained in a simple and easy to follow
away specifically what I'll cover is
what a function is how they're typically
declared in JavaScript how and why you
normally use functions and of course
like always a bunch of examples as I go
along in the code to make things super
duper clear to everyone as you can see
I'm using the same setup I always do
we'll use the terminal window here to go
launch the Python server I'll just go do
that now let's go here and and there we
go that'll just let us host the files
and run this from the browser I've
already got Adam open here and I've
created a new project javascript
beginners 4 and i've got chrome here
we'll just open the developer tab at the
console here and lastly we should go
navigate to localhost if you haven't
already check out my first video in the
series which covers environment setup if
you want to follow along exactly the
same way I do it feel free to skip this
next part because what I'm going to talk
about is functions but in a more
abstract way because well JavaScript
functions for beginners this might be
really useful if say you've never done
any programming before but if you
already have a grasp on the subject then
go ahead and skip a bit later in the
video so like I said we're talking about
functions and the first thing we should
go over is what exactly is a function
now if you remember back to the video
where I described what a variable is a
variable is an abstraction a way to give
a symbolic name to a piece of
information set another way a variable
is I could contain therefore some data
that you want to store and refer to
later so if you're asking like what does
that have to do with functions the
concepts are more similar than you think
so why am I talking about variables when
we're talking about functions in this
video the concepts are more similar than
you think
while the variable refers to a sort of
tainer for a piece of data a function is
like a container but instead of being
for data a function is like a container
for a piece of code that you want to
reuse over and over again maybe in a
different way or maybe in a different
context let's take an example that shows
how variables and functions operate
together you want to describe to someone
how to calculate the tip at the end of a
meal so you tell them normally it's
about 15% of the cost of the meal
although ever service was really bad
maybe give less and if service was
superb maybe give more in that case
there's a few variables there's the cost
of the meal and the quality of the
service let's just write those out
Boston meal quality service and let's
let's give those names that look more
like JavaScript variables cost you the
to calculate the tip there's some steps
to perform and we use those variables to
get the answer how much should I tip
let's write some what I'll call
pseudocode it's not going to be a real
code it's just intended to look like
code but you should be able to follow
along in plain English we'll call this
thing the tip calculator and if the
quality of service was just okay then
tip maybe 15% and the quality of service
was great then tip let's say 30% and the
quality of the service was just terrible
then tip will be will be drunks here and
what's up zero so the total tip is the
cost of meal times the tip that we
decided
the function here is the repeatable
steps it's the steps involved in
deciding how much to tip and then
calculating the size of the tip based
off of the cost of the meal the function
relies on a few variables all of which
change with every meal and with every
person and those variables are the cost
of the meal and the quality of the
service or the perceived quality of the
service is that was that clear to
everyone looping back around javascript
functions explained in other ways that
they're a way of wrapping up a piece of
the code or a section of the code so
that it can be used again in different
contexts in much the same way that the
tipping calculation can now be reused by
everyone at the table they just need to
input how much the meal cost how good
they thought the service was and they
get an answer they get an answer of how
much they should tip in a lot of ways a
function is like a mini program it's a
small piece of the program that can be
run over and over again in different
ways so now that we know what a function
is let's move on to how to declare a
function in JavaScript and there's a
couple ways to define a function in
JavaScript if you're really curious and
I encourage you to visit the MDM Web
Docs that's Mozilla's comprehensive
website on development documentation for
web standards and they have huge
sections dedicated to JavaScript
functionality including stuff like
browser compatibility which is really
nice so you can see whether or not a
feature of JavaScript is supported just
on Chrome or just on Firefox or across a
wide variety of browsers let's go and
visit that right now yeah these are the
mdn web docs from Mozilla you can see
that there's a big section here on
functions and it's very comprehensive
here but also if we scroll up you can
see that we've got a lot of reference
for not only functions but all of
JavaScript and I use this extensively
when I'm learning about JavaScript
all right back to how to define a
function in JavaScript like I said
there's a few ways but I don't want to
get too caught up in all that right now
since you're new so I'll teach you the
most common form to start and we'll work
with that
at the end of quickly show you a few of
the other ways and we won't go into much
detail as they require pretty much
entire videos on their own the important
takeaway here is that you'll know how to
declare a function and if you see a
different way in code if you're reading
someone else's code you should be able
to understand what's happening let's go
and write some actual code and what
we'll do here is we'll write a function
that does some console dot log
statements like we've been using before
so here we go
let's just erase all of this stuff here
and a function will just write something
doesn't matter now to deconstruct what
we actually wrote here I started with
the function keyword so you can see the
function keyword right here and that's
one of those reserved keywords in
JavaScript and what it does is it says
that we're about to declare a function
similar to how we used let constant or
var to declare variables you use the
function keyword to declare a JavaScript
function then we follow that up with the
name so right here we've got the name of
the function and again this is exactly
the same as when you declared variables
and finally you can see between the two
curly braces here I've got the console
log statement this is called the
function body and you can write a bunch
of code here between those two curly
braces in fact the same restrictions on
naming variables also applied to naming
functions now have you missed that video
I encourage you to go back and watch it
but to summarize you can use either an
underscore or alphabetic characters to
start that's including capitals or
lowercase and then alphanumeric like
eight is the zero nine or underscores
for the rest of the name let's go and
run this now
let's go in chrome and hit reload so
you'll notice that nothing happened and
that's because all we did was declare a
function the program knows that the
function exists now like write some
stuff exists it's a thing in the program
but that's all it's doing it's existing
there was no code actually run so to
make it run and execute and actually do
something this is called calling a
function in JavaScript and the way you
call it is let's just go to the code
here and write some stuff then you add a
parenthesis afterwards we'll get to why
later and then the semicolon and then we
just go and reload here and there we go
hello how are you you can see that it
ran now cuz it printed out the hello how
are you that we added in the code before
and we can go and we can call this twice
for example it was just reload and you
can see that it printed out hello how
are you twice so this is neat but it's
not doing a heck of a lot here so let's
add a little bit of complexity let's
make the write some stuff function take
an argument so we'll go back here we'll
add an argument called stuff and we'll
just change the internals of the
function a little bit so that it writes
out stuff now this word here stuff this
is an argument to the function which is
basically like a variable that only
exists inside of the function like the
only thing that can refer to it is code
that's inside the function that's the
code between this curly brace and this
curly brace and now and the way you call
this function is by doing this so let's
just get rendered one of these for now
and I
right in here I'll pass a string I
actually don't like apples I don't know
why I wrote that now we go and hit
reload and stuff I like apples this is
kind of cool
stewed viewers might have realized this
by now console.log is a function and
we've been calling it this whole time
and passing in an argument we've been
passing it an argument we've been
passing it what we want to show up in
the console a string now if we go to the
console you'll actually be able to see
this so I go here and I type type of
console log and you can see that it is a
function in much the same way that
writes some stuff is also a function
let's go a bit further now and we'll
make that tipping function that we
talked about earlier so this is going to
be a little bit more complicated let's
define a new function here so let's just
get rid of all of this stuff and we'll
call a calculate tip meal cost the curly
braces the curly braces here everything
between them is the code of the function
we go here and we're going to say let
tip size equals new cost times 15% and
we're just gonna write out some quick
log statements here console.log the Neil
cost was Neil cost go let's write out
the tip
good be size and then the total cost is
the total is dududu before we run this I
just want to point out that you may have
noticed that I used a variable in here
let tip size equal the meal cost times
15% what I did here was I declared a
variable inside the function and the
interesting thing about that is like the
argument the argument here meal cost tip
size only exists within the function
this is called scope and it means as
soon as the function ends that variable
ceases to exist in the function to give
an example of that let's just call the
function so calculate tip and the say
that the meal was exactly $10 the meal
was $10 the tip should be a dollar 50
the total is 11:50 that's about right
now if we go in here and we try and use
tip size console dot log tip size you
might think because the tip size was 1.5
that this is going to log 1.5 but in
actuality tip size is not defined as I
mentioned tip size only exists for the
duration of the function that's when the
function starts and when it ends it gets
created right here and it only exists
for a short time before going away again
when the function ends that's when the
variable goes what's called out of scope
and no longer exists let's get rid of
this and we'll add a second argument to
the tip function now let's call it drink
cost
so the reason I added a second variable
is you can notice that I just used a
comma to declare it I didn't have to do
anything fancy all I have to do is add a
comma and then the name of the next
argument and the way we call this as we
go to calculate tip and we just added a
comma here and let's say that the drink
was $5 you got a fancy juice or one of
those sparkling waters and then we run
it out we actually have to modify a
calculate tip to take that into account
there we go and there we go
the meal cost was fifteen dollars that's
ten plus five the tip should be 225 the
total is 1725 that's exactly what you
should expect now the last thing I want
to cover here is that a function can do
some work but you can also get
JavaScript to return a value from a
function maybe you don't want to just
calculate the tip and then print it out
but maybe you want to get the number so
that you can add it up for everyone at
the table let's modify the function yet
again so first off I'm just going to
simplify this a little bit
just gonna get into this I can get rid
of these and what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna return the value so now so
the return keyword is a reserved keyword
in JavaScript much the same way that
function and var and Latin cuz those are
all reserved keywords this is a reserved
keyword it tells JavaScript that you
want to save the value in this case tip
size and you want to pass it back to the
spot that called the function now when I
call this nothing happens but I can use
the value and then it'll show up so
let's go and do that let's just print it
out so I do a console log and hit reload
we should print it out there we go
225 and you can save it so instead of
using consult log let's save it to a
variable go here would remove this now
we'll call this again so let's go here
that tip to equal calculate and let's
say the second meal is 20 dollars and
they didn't have anything to drink and
we'll do some console dot log here log
tip 1
now let's go to Chrome and reload and
there we go you can see tip 1 was saved
225 tip 2 was saved $3 so the total tips
was 525 those were written out here so
we have a console dot log that writes
out tip 1 and tip 2 and then we have a
final console dot log that writes out
the combined tip 1 plus tip 2 now
earlier I said there were multiple ways
to define a function and there are the
one that we've been using up until now
is called function declaration so that's
use the keyword function followed by the
name and then all the arguments and the
body of the function but there's a few
other ways I'm going to go through a few
of the others just for completeness sake
now so you'll know they exist you'll
know roughly what they do and if you
want I encourage you to modify the
examples in this tutorial and try to use
the other ways of declaring a function
instead of the function declaration way
so another really common way is to use
what's called a function expression I'll
get rid of all this code to start to do
and it looks like this
this is called exactly the same way
nothing really changes just going right
some right and more stuff then go and
reload and writing more stuff so going
over this a little bit we have the
function keyword here and there's no
name after it
this creates what's called an anonymous
function expression it doesn't have a
name but since we assigned it to a
variable that's that's the thing you can
do you can still refer to it by using
write more stuff and you can see that
this is still a function which is use
console.log type of write and more stuff
and there you go it's still a function
in this example we've created what was
called an anonymous function expression
you can also create a named function
expression so so I'll just go here and
I'll copy this
now let's hit reload you can see that it
wrote more stuff again this time from
named so we got writing more stuff
function writing more stuff function the
the type of write more stuff and write
more stuff again we're both functions
still this is called a named function
expression and one of the major
differences between it and the anonymous
function expression is that it has a
name as you can probably tell the reason
that you give it a name is because if
you have an error in your code and it's
an ax named function versus an anonymous
function you may just have a little bit
more information about what happened
so sometimes it's useful just to give it
a name but you don't have to now if
you're wondering here what the
difference is between the function
expressions and the function
declarations that were using throughout
the tutorial the really big one is this
so I'm just gonna get rid of a lot of
this stuff we're gonna keep the
anonymous one for now and let's go here
and I'm gonna use a and I'm going to
declare a function the way that we were
declaring it earlier function this is
this
now from the name you might be able to
tell what's gonna happen but I'm gonna
run it here so I'm going to call the
function this ran successfully now the
really interesting part is I can put it
before the functions declaration and it
still works and the reason for that is
because this function this exists no
matter what exists as soon as the file
is loaded and parsed now if you try to
do that with the function expression you
go to write more stuff here and you try
and use it before it was created this is
gonna error out because in the second
case in the function expression case the
function only exists after this line of
code is hit that's the biggest
difference between these two and yes
there's other reasons why you might want
to use one or the other but let's just
ignore that for now it's we're getting
into an advanced topic and we'll get to
that down the road lastly there are
what's called arrow functions just get
rid of the code here and let arrow
function equals
here we go and reload oops did run it
when we reload we see I'm an arrow
function this is really similar to the
function expressions in fact you
actually have to go and assign it to a
variable just like a function expression
if you want to save it for the sake of
simplicity you can consider them
basically to be the same thing that is
arrow functions and function expressions
there are differences between the two
but we'll have to do much deeper dive on
the differences later so here's a
challenge were you able to change the
code to use function expressions or
arrow functions let me know if you did
in which one you tried and that about
wraps up this video in the series I
really hope you enjoyed it and I'll see
you again soon Cheers